welcome back to New rockstars and
Princess sure he wasn't the only
powerful woman who got a promotion in
wakanda Forever Evil Elaine from
Seinfeld also known as Val got promoted
to the head of the CIA after throwing
her ex-husband under the bus for
betraying the country just because
Everett wanted to be invited to the
cookout that's so stupid like he's just
let him betray the country a little bit
all right but uh nah I think that's
something sinister is brewing in Val's
sneaky brain okay I don't think that
she's just looking out for the country I
think that Val's brain could secretly be
surrounded by a Red Skull this is Rogue
Theory the show we pitched the wildest
theories for the energy titles that we
love a show made possible by the support
of the lovely people at nordvpn more of
those beautiful human beings in a little
bit so my name is Mt and Gordon roll
with me today is the most wonderful
wonderful wakanda forever breakdowner in
the world it's Jessica Clemens what's
going on guys if you guys not have if
you guys have not seen that breakdown go
watch that because Jessica Clemens goes
in
um all day every day no it's really
funny which I just realized uh there's a
piece of Whitney's breakdown in my
breakdown
I put Wednesday's breakdown of the
midnight Angels into my breakout so you
also get
um
and if you watch my breakdown on the
costumes I also throw to this video of
Jessica's she'll also get to see a
little picture of Jessica pop-up in my
video which is fun
so guess what guess what me and Jessica
are friends and we like each other hi
give me give me I love friends actually
no keep going I just spilled green juice
all over myself oh my gosh oh the pickle
juice
every time this is the ag1 today's spill
brought to you by athletic greens and
one of the best friends in the world
it's Winnie vanland again what's going
on Whitney
and of course my brother from another
mother it is Brandon Barrick what's
going on T it's so good to see you again
so good to be back on Rogue theater I
feel like it's been so long and I have
so much it's been so long since we've
been on a rogue Theory together building
up inside of me and it wants to just
explode out of my pores you're going
back to your off screen producer Brandon
days and I don't like it I need to be on
screen for me a screen producer Brandon
I'm doing this great producer Brandon
all day every day if you're on screen
you better be bottomless and that's it
I I didn't make the rules I didn't make
the rules bottomless Brandon's let's go
let's order that at brunch
let's go into our first topic for today
because I have a feeling that there
could be a life possibility here that
Val can Tessa Valentina Allegra de
Fontaine um the first I don't know is an
avatar for the Red Skull and um there's
a couple reasons why I believe this and
we know from um like the comics that um
Contessa Valentina Allegra de Fontaine
was Madame Hydra um for a little bit and
um and we also know that Captain America
New World Order is coming up and New
World Order the actual New World Order
organization was a hydro organization
run by The Red Skull and um if you look
at like the way the Val dresses
especially in uh Falcon of the Winter
Soldier and the end of black widow she
dresses a lot like the Red Skull and I
feel like that is intentional she wears
like red she has like the I know she
dresses like um Red Skull in his uniform
back when he was a uh being Peak [__]
and uh I want to look this up lots of
like I don't remember
my favorite ponytail and you can see
that perfect line through I remember it
the purple hair yeah
and velso very interested in super
soldiers like Red Skull she uh like runs
up to
um Johnny mayonnaise and he's like hey
you look really nice and yeah I like how
you took the serum it's real nice also
we know from uh Avengers Infinity war
and end game that Red Skull was on for
me or so like everyone's like how does
Red Skull get from warmir to the planet
Earth and I understand what you guys are
thinking however if you remember from
like after the sacrifice is made on
vormir a huge beam of Lights much like
the beam of light that's sent from Red
Skull 2 vormir in the first place
happens and I think that through that
beam of light he was sent through the
cosmos and potentially into the brain of
um or the body of a Contessa Valentina
Allegre de Fontaine who could
potentially be like a descendant or um
or something but like I think the reason
why Val wears a a little a purple streak
in her hair is because it's Marvel's way
of like teasing the red skulls obsession
with the tesseracting like meshing it
together and making purple it's like hey
and like red and blue together make
purple
exactly take that back to elementary
school I still don't think that's
correct I still don't think that's right
but like you know we we saw from um from
Infinity war end game that like the Red
Skull was like this weird ghost form
like he's like a weird like wraith he's
got somewhere he's a bottomless right
he's bottomless yeah
[Music]
let's just clarify because we have a lot
of sayings here at new rock stars eating
ain't cheating three bang now we have
bottomless Brandon's as always this is
not dirty this is not a dirty this is a
pair a line of his slacks that he
actually says yeah exactly
so it's like it's bottomless because it
never ends you know and there is no end
there was no end no end in sight it
sounds like the name of like a fable
it's the tail of bottomless brands
[Music]
um but no um I think that there's a
possibility here that we could be
setting up a potential resurrection of
The Red Skull in the MCU
um because the Red Skull is one of the
most iconic Captain America villains
ever that's his main villain and to get
rid of him and take him off the table
after Captain America won and just set
him up into space never to be seen again
not realistic I don't I don't buy that
for a second I think that Marvel Studios
is setting Val up to be the new Red
Skull and uh she's gonna one day she's
gonna rip off her mask like her daddy or
whatever or loretical be like hey it's
me I have a disease under here actually
just like Red Skull all right uh what do
you guys think I have a question and I
have a comment I'll use my question oh
yeah I'll do both but I'll do the
question first uh I like the idea of her
being a descendant of red school I also
do thoroughly agree with you I think the
way red school just disappeared isn't
good enough so I do think he'd be coming
back do you think he could just be a
variant or she could be a variant of red
School there's a different Universe
where red school is a woman and his
Valentina Val that is a fantabulous I
freaking love that point because that is
so true we know from what if that there
was a Red Skull that potentially opened
up a gateway to another Universe with a
weird tentacle people that were coming
from so like there's the possibility
that another Red Skull variant did the
same thing and actually went through a
portal and um went and ended up another
Universe much like um Captain Carter did
at the end of what if so yeah I like
that idea a lot where it's like hey it's
another variant uh there's no Red Skull
here so I'm just gonna be the Redstone
in this universe because why not uh the
non-gen
um and my one comment is I like the idea
that it's maybe the blue strip but once
you just assume the blue stripe in her
hair you know how like people have like
a birthmark on their skull and it makes
their hair white do you have one oh
Brandon has one it does that hit oh
she said that's where the devil touched
me okay never mind
so back to what I would say no
oh my God
of kids are like yeah my mom said like
that's where an angel touched me or
that's where like a star fell from the
sky or your grandma's like yeah well
you're going to hell
I love that Grandma I love that Grandma
it's the mock of the Beast do you think
there could just be the possibility that
like this is a horrible analogy but like
uh Anna and Elsa and Frozen she got like
sniped by like a king and got that Blue
Streak in her hair
I'm not trying
to do I'm just saying
that would be like really interesting it
that was like a side effect of like some
type of transfer I don't know but really
I like that idea yeah overall I mean
they kind of uh you know Rogue the X-Men
famously has like the white streak in
the hair and they they in the fox
Universe right they invented a reason
why she had like that white streak just
like a character Choice when when she
was stopping Magneto from doing the
device uh yeah like it permanently gave
her the streak in her hand Statue of
Liberty um it also well that idea
Jessica kind of relates to like Greek
mythology right Achilles the reason
Achilles has the one weak spot in his
heel is because when he was dipped in
the water that made him like The
Greatest Warrior and made him like
Invincible where he was held at the heel
that spot was like never covered with
the water so that's why he was he has
like that one weakness right there you
think uh God took Valentina by the hair
strand is like
a baby soft spot and if you poke her in
the Blue Streak it's like a destruct
button her Fontanel have never closed up
fully and so now she's got this purple
shirt
that's just her soft spot we
is my baby soft
now empty and your your initial Theory
here you did use the term Avatar do you
see Val as like yeah an avatar of red
skull and he's like influencing her and
he's like speaking to her oh like the
Green Goblin to Norman Osborne he's like
in her head or is he like that's why
it's a Blue Streak she's parked
she sees you
um or is it like yeah like the Red Skull
right he's stuck on Boromir his job is
to guard the Soul Stone it's gone so
vormir's like you can leave now he's
like great I'm out of here and he comes
back to Earth and he's like man I feel
like a woman and he just like takes the
form of a woman like he wants to be nice
to himself
he finally he's able to express himself
because in like Nazi Germany he is not
allowed to express himself as a female
he's supposed to be the strong leader
and he's like super Nazi right he's more
Nazi than that he's like I'm all the way
now and he's like I can't be dressing
like a woman they want to respect me uh
but now he can finally take on his full
form as a woman
is Val actually Red Skull or is she
being influenced by Red Skull and you're
a theory what which do you you see it
I think that Val is being I think it's
it might be a mix of both I think I
think it might be like a Green Goblin
situation where like Val might have been
like a javelin situation we got one of
those on our hands
classic it happens to everyone one of
those bad boys
you know um I think that you know like
like there's a possibility that Val
could have been a normal woman living on
Earth and then Red Skull like beams into
our bodies like all right now I got Red
Skull personality and so like which
would which would explain how she
introduces herself um to
um Captain America uh well Captain
Johnny Walker USA um
I'm trying not to say Johnny manners
because they want to be mean to him well
yes Johnny Ben is
um
we're being mean to Johnny Mannix
not my taxes look not my taxes not my
money not my monster not my monster not
my circus
when Val introduces herself to John and
Walker she's like my name is like Val
but like she goes okay no my real name
is Contessa Valentina but you can call
me Val it's like but don't call me Val
because like I'm actually the Reds go
but you can call me Val because like I
think that he's just like getting used
to the bodies like call me Val but like
is this is a [__] act so like we
don't have to really does that explain
why Everett Ross and Val broke up like
the woman he married was not influenced
by let's go go weather waiting I was
gonna say do you think that this is like
like
like a scroll scenario in which
thunderful wife lady Val Who Loved
Martin Freeman so much and she was like
oh my God Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy was good babe and she like loved
him you know like like maybe that
version of her got replaced by Red Skull
and then she was like [__] I want a
divorce and also I [__] hate you and
like then just like lived her life as an
[__] from then on out like that's my
I think if if it happened that's my
theory on it I do love I love that it
would make a lot of sense she did say
that she's had a lot of mean things
right um towards the end of their
marriage so like right maybe you could
have been me Nazi stuff yeah yeah
it just starts reading mind Camp it's
like everyone's like I don't know about
this
it can still happen we don't
we don't he's back there she was before
you know she was always like Everett
you're always leaving the toilet seat up
and it really pisses me off also we
should invade Poland let's go everybody
and everyone's like you should not marry
this one yeah that's a red flag I'm just
trying to have dinner but also like this
would be like having a vowel secretly be
the Red Skull would be very much in line
with the luck that Everett Ross the
character in the comics has because that
dude was like the most unluckiest dude
ever like he's most of the most
unluckiest agents ever so like having
him be like oh no I secretly dated the
head of Hydra or buried to her like that
would be like the biggest like oh I
goofed
oh man I goofed
accidentally married a Nazi sympathizer
whoops what happens to Grimes anyway
[Laughter]
but yes no what do you guys think of
this theory of of Val being secretly
being the Red Skull do you guys think
that like the Red Skull it's possible
that the Red Skull could have
infiltrated her body in ghost form or is
this Theory to bogus rogus bogus or ogis
take it away Brandon I think you've made
a compelling argument here Mt I'm gonna
give this a rocus I do like this idea of
of the Reds I do want the Reds go back
love the Red Skull uh uh love what they
love that character would love to see
more of them we're so happy to see him
in Infinity war and in game uh let's
bring him back I do like it and I like
the idea that yeah he somehow uh taking
power now I don't want to give Val uh I
want to give Val out of agency here too
so I want I I don't like the idea that
she's being manipulated I I want her to
choose to be with Red Skull but I do
like the idea so I will give it a rogus
yes so you want her to choose to be I
want her to choose evil you know what
yeah
truly a feminist
this is a very branding thing to say
he's okay
[Laughter]
thank you
oh what do you think Whitney
um no I think this is rogus as hell uh
although I'm I'm going with my theory I
think she was replaced I think that'd be
a great reason for their divorce I think
it would be sick if she was somehow like
replaced by like the ghost of The Red
Skull or like the spirit or like The
Descendant or somehow like I think that
that would be really really interesting
uh so I'm giving I'm gonna get I'm gonna
double rogus one rogus for your theory
one Rogue is for my new Theory sorry yes
I'll give you August Vine for your
spirit as well uh what do you think
Jessica I was gonna say bogus until you
said brand it's on brandor or whatever
no I disagree
um I was gonna give it a rogus because
you know I like Rogue theories and that
was Rogue that was very rude okay but
also I would love to see it so I guess
I'm very biased because I'm like I just
want to see it
I just want to see Elaine be evil yeah I
just want to see him yeah I just want to
see evil Elaine I think I just want to
see it as a really good reason to vote
Yes
half the time that's why yeah I should
think about that maybe if I just don't
want to see it I'm like bogus
you have to speak truth to power you
gotta you gotta manifest these things
yeah it's it's true it's true well
thanks guys thank you for listening to
my theories but buckle up because up
next Whitney has the most incredible
Fast and the Furious Rogue theory that
you will ever hear but first be sure to
head on over to nerd riot.shop where you
can grab one or even two of our many
awesome new shirts inspired by Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania these shirts
are amazing I'm wearing one of the
hoodies right now the conquer hoodie I
freaking love this hoodie it's so
freaking dope Brandon's got some stuff
on like we like these are these designs
are amazing what's special about this
shirt empty oh yeah you're wearing my
shirt well I I just it's my idea and
then a wonderful talented artist I'm not
wearing clothes and don't worry yeah he
raided my closet while I was sleeping I
have nothing left
um I have to go to TJ Maxx right now
that's also why they call him bottomless
Brandon because he only steals shirts
that's right exactly only shirts I only
have pants which is great thank you
brother
um but there's and there's still time to
order some now and have it delivered in
time to wear on opening weekend of
quantumania I even helped with one of
those designs featuring Kang the man of
conquering so you can support the
channel and check out all of our awesome
merch options over at nerd riot.shop we
also want to thank nordvpn for
sponsoring this video podcast because
have you ever gotten extremely hyped to
watch a new series or film oh would you
discover it's not available for
streaming in your country well nordvpn
has got you covered with your VPN you
can switch your virtual location on your
device with one click giving you the
ability to access streaming services
from over 60 countries at no extra cost
this opens up a Quantum realm full of
entertaining content which you wouldn't
be able to access without nordvpn and
with over 5400 servers in 60 countries
nordvpn gives you access to games and
streaming platforms that are currently
not available in your region and the
best part is nordvpn will not slow down
your online experience they've done the
speed test and nor VPN is the fastest
VPN out there they've done the science
that it is the fastest and they even
help keep you safe from hackers
malicious sites and pop-ups while
browsing the internet all with just one
click the Power of One Click can you
guys believe it if you're a rogue Theory
fan you can help support the show and
grab your exclusive nor VPN deal by
going to nordvpn.com Rogue Theory you'll
get a huge discount off your nordvpn
plan plus a bonus gift it's completely
risk-free with Nord 30-day money-back
guarantee that's nordvpn.com Rogue
Theory we also want to thank bespoke
Post for sponsoring this video podcast
because every month has one day that is
more awesome than all the rest that's
the day that your box of awesome arrives
from bespoke post every box of Awesome
from both spoke post contains incredible
items that will make your kitchen your
wardrobe or even the outdoors more
awesome that's really one of the coolest
things about bespoke post every unique
item is hand curated from a small
business that you probably would have
never heard of otherwise from cozy
Essentials to a travel must-haves and
cocktail kits box of awesome has
everything you need this month so to get
started take the quiz at
boxofawesome.com and your answers will
help them pick the right box of awesome
for you they release new boxes every
month across a ton of different
categories each box is valued at around
70 dollars but you pay only a fraction
of that price plus with each box of
awesome you're supporting small
businesses ninety percent of everything
that comes in your box of awesome is
from a small up and coming brand it's
free to sign up and you can skip a month
or cancel any time so get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
box of awesome.com enter the code Rogue
at checkout that's boxofawesome.com code
Rogue for 20 off your first box box of
awesome.com code Rogue all right guys
now it is time for the lovely Whitney
bad lining him to take out away the
second topic take it away Whitney all
right folks ladies and gentlemen at home
in your car doing laundry folding
laundry mowing your lawn with your
headphones in wherever you're at please
listen up yes I've had this theory for a
really long time it is about Fast and
the Furious uh full disclosure got a
shout out my very sweet fiance Brett and
Turley very nice guy he actually brought
this Theory to my attention tension and
then the two of us expanded on it
together however I must give him initial
credit as you guys may or may not know
Fast and the Furious trailer we're
shooting this today on Thursday tomorrow
Friday the Fast and the Furious trailer
comes out but y'all are listening to
this on Saturday so hopefully yeah
you've already watched you've just
watched the trailer you watched me and
Tommy break it down for you we're doing
that hope you watched it can you tune
into that and now you know things about
it so uh what you may not have picked up
on however is that every Fast and the
Furious movie has escalated to
ridiculous proportions for the next
movie for the next movie for the next
movie but I've been doing a re-watch all
this past week to get ready for this
trailer dropping and I've noticed that
almost everything that has happened in
the Fast and the Furious no matter how
ridiculous has at one point been
foreshadowed in a previous movie and so
what I am theorizing today is that in
the next movie Vin Diesel will have to
drag race Satan himself or another
Supernatural entity I like it because
there's nowhere else for this series to
go at this point in fast nine in the
last movie they went to space they went
to space fast seven they jumped through
three separate skyscrapers in Dubai in a
car like they've been in the ocean
they've been underground they've been in
caves they've been literally everywhere
the only place that they haven't gone is
to a supernatural realm of some kind or
Hell itself I I
it's gonna be hell itself because I
think that that's the next like
realistic thing that they can do is like
burrow into the Earth
um but my evidence
yeah I think that Vin Diesel's gonna go
downstairs
yeah I think that they're gonna have to
do that but every movie is kind of like
predicted the next one right so like if
you go back to the first one it's you
know they say something about oh if we
were doing this on boats what happens
the next movie they do it on a boat
I rewatched I think which one was I
think it was Fast Five last night Fast
Five ludicrous makes a joke about them
having to go to space they go to space
in fast nine uh going under another one
they made a prediction oh what are we
gonna do like jump jump out of an
airplane or whatever they drive cars out
of a helicopter like they they always do
the thing that they joke about doing so
in the ninth movie there's a whole scene
where uh Tyrese Gibson realizes that
they have all like just like survived
everything like they've all none of them
have died oh yeah sorry they brought
someone back from the dead right this is
why I'm this is why I'm not good at
Rogue Theory because my thoughts are so
all over the place I never do my own
theories because they're so hard to
follow and I'm really sorry but a fun
fact about the fast Universe really
quick is that they bring back characters
to life all the time right and also for
some reason Paul Walker's character is
still alive in the franchise Paul Walker
the actor is dead yeah he he just went
on to raise a family but he's still
alive because they still talk about him
in each movie and they're like oh yeah
you talked to Brian O'Connor lately and
they're like Brian's doing great so are
the kids like and so they do that all
the time so he's the he's like actually
still alive in the Fast and the Furious
you know universe and is ironically the
only person in the Fast and the Furious
universe who can't actually come back to
life because almost everybody in the
franchise has died and come back to life
um including Vin Diesel Vin Diesel dies
in fast seven and comes back to life in
past seven it's nuts so back to fast
nine fast nine they uh they're talking
about
um how it's nuts that they're going into
space and they're probably gonna die and
it's wild and uh ludicrous and Tyrese
are just talking about like hey do you
think that maybe we're Immortal because
none of us have ever actually died doing
any of these things like Han came back
to life Vin Diesel came back to life
like everyone has even if they've gotten
like Gravely injured have somehow ended
up Surviving and
um obviously the rest of the crew is
like making fun of them and they're like
no there's no way you guys are so dumb
like this is impossible it's not
possible
I don't know I think it's possible I
think it's possible that the fast crew
is Immortal and I think that Satan has
somehow blessed them with their powers
and I think that they are cursed and
Immortal at the same time and what I
think that they're going to do is I
think that they're going to go to hell
to rescue gal gadot's soul and have her
character come back from the next one
okay okay I'm so sorry it was all over
the place I sincerely apologize so
they're kind of cursed immortally kind
of like the Pirates of the Caribbean
right like they want to die but they
can't die like they're just stuck in
this life of racing and they it never
ends I think your biggest I love this I
love this Whitney and I want to see them
race the devil I don't even say what I'm
gonna say I'm gonna choke you okay well
I would say is I love that the poster we
got for fast 10. it's Vin Diesel holding
the rosary yeah
since the first fast movie he's the son
of God he's the greatest racer of all
time and the sexiest man
um as you can tell from the triple X
franchise where all the all the women
want to sleep with Vin Diesel in that
franchise well I think they're
contractually obligated unfortunately
sorry your character has to do it I I am
the producer of these movies sorry I
don't know
um I I would like the idea too of the of
this being like a lost scenario where
Vin Diesel actually died in the first
race in the first movie and like entered
in a crash and he's just soul is like no
I'm still alive but I have all these
friends and this family
but it's like he died 20 years ago he's
been dead and this is just like nobody
around here's the name Dominic Toretto
for 40 years
the big nitrous explosion of 1907. I I
would love that like I think it'd be
hilarious if they can't die because of a
nitrous explosion or like they just
drank nitrous it's like you know what we
can't die now
but no I like that I really like this
idea of the fast franchise just going
super crazy yeah I'm like not I like how
it just it just doesn't take itself
super seriously but also is super super
freaking dope with all the action so
like I would love to see like a freaking
tournament in hell yeah just like you
know what let's just freaking race it's
very stupid all this crazy stuff it's
very seven feel right like you have to
play chess with with death uh in order
and for your soul like the idea that
you're Racing for your soul I think it's
a lot of fun can I say something can
on our sweet sweet program two things
where does Hobbs and Shaw fit on this
list it doesn't fit
Hobbs and Shaw Shaw is the only
work Vin Diesel because
not friends not like each other and The
Rock has completely like sworn him off
like doesn't even acknowledge that he's
in the fast films anymore like he hates
that game I've seen those videos but has
that being the last Fast and Furious
movie I see I've seen and it involves
them going to Hawaii and fighting with a
lot of Hawaiians is there an opportunity
that this movie how does that does it
fit in the phases of the Fast and
Furious could they just be like they're
like they mentioned Hawaii and Ops and
shots so the next film they're in Hawaii
for fast 10.
honestly
B uh but I think that I think that Hobbs
and Shaw aren't cursed like the family
is I think that you have to be in the
family and yeah
second question oh what if they all just
die
can that happen where they all just die
I mean eventually I don't know because
because there's like predictions made in
fast nine they always follow through on
the predictions and I really think that
because it was predicted that they can't
die I think that they can't die dude I
just think they can I like the idea of
him being like we must be immortal and
then they die in the next film and then
they die in the next one and it's like
just kidding fast 10 yes you know it
would be super crazy like this is
obviously ridiculous but like if they
did a Ghost Rider crossover yes with
Fast and Furious
like these guys are too long
you're like it's just the fast family
just running away from Ghost Rider what
do you guys think Eric would do if the
first time we see Mephisto in the MCU is
at the end of fast 10. what do you think
well I mean you're touching on some like
quantum theory here a little bit right
the idea that by uh in quantum physics
and I'm gonna I'm gonna screw this up
but like our very Act of observing
something changes it even if we don't
mess with it by observing something we
we change it and if we don't watch it it
does something different so like the
idea that we as an audience are watching
these Fast and the Furious movies and we
keep putting money into them and they
keep doing well at the box office
despite many other projects failing
somehow they keep going like they can't
die because of our observation like if
they put out a movie where they all die
and no one sees it then they can die and
then they can be dead and then they're
dead forever Dominic Torero's house is
not far from us right because it has the
most traffic
and I only know this because I have to
go to an ice skating rink nearby it and
yeah it was The Goonies House people
always go to The Goonies house or they
go to The Nightmare on Elm Street house
or like you know it used to be the Brady
Bunch house over there is the worst bro
like geez well the traffic's because of
Dominic Torero it's his fault yeah
all Vin Diesel's and Jessica you brought
up Hobson shot right that movie it's
like Hobbs and shot they none of them
ever lose a fight right because of their
contracts in the real world like they
none of them could lose the fights so
they're kind they're stuck in the
struggle of no winning no losing this
concept because they got so close to the
family they're not part of the family
they got close to it and it started
affecting them and they're like I can't
they're stuck in the central crisis
right and so like whoever the
antagonists are in the in this movie and
each Fast and the Furious movie right in
theory if if Whitney's theory is true
that these guys are Immortal they can't
die our antagons are our protagonists
right they're the ones trying to stop
this madness trying to get rid of these
people but they can't so we should
always be rooting for the bad guy in
these Fast and Furious movies for the
sake of these Souls that need to be for
the sake of Dominic treado's Soul so it
can finally race
can I add one last thing three homes
they disliked us and said this is all
going to end with dom drag racing the
reaper to protect his family he's
already won he's already won once in
secret Roman figured out uh figured that
out a little in nine but eventually
death comes to take what's due that is
this is a fifth person Theory right now
see he said
any of these Supernatural figures
honestly I wouldn't be I would not be
surprised I mean and I don't think it's
going to be Supernatural like vampires
or like bringing the names of monster or
whatever I think it's gonna be
specifically like
Satan Grim Reaper death you can't beat
down that's correct like no because Vin
Diesel is the Christ figure yeah Vin
Diesel is yeah I'm telling you like if
they if they don't do the the devil
thing they're gonna go back in time
they're going to do time travel I want
it to be like Wacky Races though what if
it's like breakdown scars
I think the ludicrous has one of my
favorite like like in the credits like
how his name is written because it makes
me happy every time it's just it's Chris
Ludacris Bridges and I'm like yeah it is
especially uh one of my favorite
ludicrous lyrics is ludicrous man these
[__] want my last name and I'm like
they want the last name Bridges they all
want to be Mrs Bridges cool you're right
they do all the women want to be all the
women want to be Mrs Bridges
[Laughter]
um I give witness Theory a rogue piss
yes that will also give Whitney a double
rocus because I like this idea of like I
like when they get super ridiculous so
yes race the devil and win yeah and win
what do you think Jessica I said a rogue
too I don't know Fast and the Furious so
literally I will believe anything when
he tells me yeah
Tokyo Drift when I was a child and
that's a sport recycle okay
unless my car is turning into a
mechanized robot like Transformers I am
not watching him okay honestly though
yes they kind of do is the thing no like
the movies
ridiculous as they go on and [__] like
that starts to happen maybe it's that I
also don't care for Tyrese Gibson
uh
what is he fighting The Rock and why is
The Rock fighting him Tyrese is a good
person actually take that out edit that
out because he doesn't pay his child
support keep going didn't know that
ludicrous is my favorite
character is just the most perfect
character I just love him child support
everybody
now it's time for our Rogue question are
you guys ready for this yeah is it about
child support let's do it
for the Super Bowl weekend they're doing
the sports this weekend the sports
championship my goodness people are
gonna be drunk and we all know that
Rihanna is going to kill it in this
year's halftime show and everyone's
going to try to guess who will be the
special guest to join her on stage so
for today's row question I want you guys
to give me your rogue's choice of a hero
or villain to come out during Rihanna's
set for a special Cameo and entertain
the crowd you know who I think would be
uh
bunny
um oh wait it has to be a hero or
villain it could be whoever you're a
villain well I think this person's a
hero and a villain Liam Neeson
yeah and then we have a little reunion
weren't they both in the battleship
Battleship battleships
yo imagine if like the battleship PR is
still alive it's like you know this
would be great to build the
battleships
the Hasbro Cinematic Universe with uh uh
um you know Transformers it's still
there baby oh that's true battleship is
this is true they're about to make a
Cars movie about their Hot Wheels
they're working on a Hot Wheels movie
did Rihanna have a song for Battleship I
forget did she get a special joint for
that for that moment I mean she had to
have I don't know she had to have but I
don't think she did because it would
have been popular and I and I know her
entire discography that's true uh
I got two answers for this Rogue
question Jessica already knows my first
answer I think I do uh you bring out
Jubilee baby and she does the fireworks
show come on
yeah
dazzler it makes more sense no Jubilee
dazzler no Jubilee
this is like a little real world uh and
I stole this one from my wife shout out
Whitney uh for stealing stuff
plagiarism
and it's great when uh umbrella hits
she's gonna do umbrella you know it you
know who comes out to dance baby
Spider-Man Tom Holland he redoes it his
dance oh my God he comes back out baby
and does it live he doesn't lose their
[__]
I can watch that again it is so good it
is so good and Zendaya would propose to
Tom at that point
baby she saw it live she was Bruno Mars
I know she was Bruno Mars
yeah he better show up I just want to
vote for Brandon's now can I just do
that like I don't care that's what I
want I don't give a [__] what I wanted I
want this now
I do like that a lot
um you don't have anything no I mean I
can oh what was I gonna say
um
I had something I just don't remember
to come out I will also vote for Brandon
it's like Brandon our road question
winner for today because I do want to
see uh Tom Holland do the umbrella thing
again I just want Tom Holland that's all
I'll let my wife
Carrie wins Carrie wins the Rogue
question
[Laughter]
um I'm Gonna Mail her her Rogue Theory
prize perfect so that'll be coming in
the mail don't send stuff to my wife but
that is it
huh empty quit sending stuff to my wife
keep my wife's bail out your
[__] mind
but that is it for this episode of Rogue
Theory thanks to our amazing guests
Jessica Clemens Whitney van landingham
and Brandon Barrick support our Channel
by checking out all of our awesome merch
over at newrockstarsmerch.com Nord
riot.shop it'll bring you to the same
place it doesn't really matter
um follow me at masterton follow me
rockstars on all social platforms and be
sure to subscribe to our channel here on
YouTube we love you guys so much we'll
see you guys next time goodbye
foreign